[Musique]
chers internautes de l'extrême
posons-nous la question qu'est-ce qu'un
film culte oui ça commence cache chacun
a une vision bien particulière de ce
qu'est un film culte mais globalement on
peut s'accorder sur le fait qu'il s'agit
d'une œuvre à la personnalité assez
forte qui traverse le temps sans voir sa
côte d'amour diminuer par exemple ça
c'est culte ça c'est pas culte ça c'est
culte ça c'est un piège souvent le film
culte a une dimension alternative plus
l'œuvre possède un cô OVNI plus son
public devient loyal et protecteurs
parfois à la limite de l'obsession et le
truc c'est que ce côté alternatif entre
parfois en contradiction avec ce qu'on
peut qualifier de grosses institutions
bien en place or le festival de Cann est
bien entendu une grosse institution bien
en place et sa récompense ultime la
Palme d'Or est l'une des plus
prestigieuse sinon la plus prestigieuse
distinction dans le monde du cinéma donc
est-ce que ça revient à dire en gros que
la palme et les films cultes sont
inconciliables c'éit une question
réthorique bon des sans spectateur et la
réponse est bien entendu non en vrac le
salaire de la peur mâche Taxi Driver
Paris Texas sex mensong et vidéo salur
et Loula et j'en passe tous plus cultes
les uns que les autres et tous plus
palmés encore que les pieds de Kevin
kosner dans waterwor mais est-ce que
c'est entièrement grâce à la palme d'or
qu'ils ont accédé à ce statut pas sûr la
palme forcément une influence sur le
destin d'un film mais elle ne fait pas
tout loin de là prenons l'archétype
absolu du film culte Poulp fiction de
Quentin Tarantino c'est un des films les
plus connus sur la planète adulé par un
nombre toujours croissant de fans en
délire mais combien d'entre nous se
souviennent que Pulp Fiction a obtenu la
Palme d'or en 19 194 pas tant que ça en
fait la Palme d'Or a eu un rôle très
important dans la carrière de Tarantino
elle lui a permis d'être pris plus au
sérieux par une partie de l'industrie
cinématographique et de développer une
grande liberté en tant que cinéaste mais
PP fiction a acquis au fil du temps une
existence propre le film s'est libéré de
son parcours et de ses titres
honorrifique en devenant reconnu
simplement pour ce qu'il est hors d'un
moment trop précis dans le temps son
statut culte il l'a acquis tout seul
comme un grand pareil pour Apocalypse
Now film culte palme d'or en
1979 tu le savais non bon là je n'ai
cité que deux exemples mais le même cas
de figure a l'air de se présenter pour
la plupart des Palmes d'or devenu culte
c'est peut-être donc ça leur paradoxe
obtenir la distinction ultime l'utiliser
comme trempelin puis parvenir à la faire
oublier aller au-delà de l'or canoise et
réussir à s'installer durablement dans
l'imaginaire des spectateurs et
qu'est-ce que tout ça nous dit sur la
sélection de
2014 j'attends force de constater que
cette sélection comporte plein de choses
différent entre habitués nouveaux vieux
jeunes originaux académiques et cetera
et cetera et à ce titre en fait elle est
complètement raccord avec ce que can a
toujours été par-delà les clichés
intellokiku le festival a toujours su
donner une place à la diversité autant
dans ses sélection que dans ces palmarès
il suffit de voir la liste de films
cultes palmés que j'ai mentionné un peu
avant on y trouve de tout des films de
genre des films d'Ar essai des grosses
machines ambitieuses des petits budgets
minimalistes tous les cas de figure se
sont produits c'est ce qui permet encore
aujourd'hui au festival de garder une
part de mystère et d'électricité et
c'est ce qui nous permet d'imaginer tous
les destins possibles cult ou non pour
les films qui sont actuellement en
compétition et donc il y a du matériel à
film culte cette année oui oui peut-être
oui non Joker on a affaire à quelques
réalisateurs dont l'œuvre est encore
assez jeune mais qui possède un
potentiel culte assez fort comme par
exemple Xavier dellan ou Michel
azanavicius on a aussi affaire à
certains cinéastes qui entretiennent
depuis longtemps des rapports très
étroits avec la notion de film culte
notamment David konenberg qui présente
cette année maps to the stars et dont la
première partie de filmographie comporte
quelques œuvres devenues absolument
mythiques désolé je ne peux pas parler
de crronenberg sans montrer cette scène
on a donc Kronenberg mais aussi entre
autres Olivia sayas qui avait réalisé le
fabuleux irmavep et concours cette année
avec sils Maria ou encore bien entendu
Jean-Luc Godard qui fait son grand
retour en compétition avec le trè méta
adieu au langage et dont la filmographie
comporte certaines œuvres plus cultes
que cultes puisquemposant des jalons
essentiels dans la Nouvelle Vague elles
ont tout simplement laissé une marque
révolutionnaire dans le cinéma mondial
ni plus ni moins mais de là à dire que
ces cinéastes ont plus de chance que les
autres d'accoucher d'une nouvelle uvre
culte il n'y a qu'un pas certes mais je
ne franchirai pas le culte reste
insaisissable et imprévisible il peut
frapper n'importe lequel des cinéastes
de la sélection à n'importe quel moment
qu'il soit récompensé ou pas et seul le
temps permettra d'en prendre la mesure
donc je crois qu'en fait il ne me reste
plus qu'à vous donner rendez-vous dans
15 ans lorsque le souvenir de l'édition
2014 sera assez lointain pour ne retenir
que l'essentiel on pourra alors
reprendre la température de tous ces
films et notamment celui qui aura reçu
la palme qui sait peut-être qu'on en
saura alors un peu plus sur les liens
entre la palme d'or et les films cultes
si entre-temps lesffan contribue à
propulser un heureux élu vers les plus
hautes Simes de la vénération
cinéphilique wait and see et c'est là
toute la beauté de la roulette russe qui
est le cinéma croyez-moi je suis en gros
plan ça appuie mon
[Musique]
propos